hello this is brad gaddis the author of
advanced google adwords along with
simply learn we're going to walk you
through the fundamentals of adwords
in this lesson we will dive deeper into
keywords to show you how you can control
how close related the search query is to
your keyword before your ad can be
displayed this is known as match types
so after completing this lesson
you should be able to identify if an ad
will show based upon the search for
query
know the difference between exact
phrase and broad matched keywords
determine how negative keywords affect
how your ad is displayed
read a search terms report and then work
with the search query data now first
let's give an overview of the match
types and their overall purpose so
a big question is what someone does a
search or at their search query will it
cause your keyword to be triggered in
your account which then makes an ad
displayed on a search page
so the search query is what someone
types in a search engine a keyword is
what's added to an ad group within your
adwords account
so when the search query matches the
keyword your ad can be displayed
so what the match type does is determine
how closely related the search query
must be to the keyword in order for your
ad to show now there's three main match
types exact phrase and broad and we'll
walk through the details of each of
these but an ad group can have all these
match types in them you can have
multiple match types for the same
keyword in your account so let's look at
the details of each match type
individually so first we have exact
match keywords now exact match keywords
only cause and add to show if the query
is the exact same as your keyword now
you can show for things like
misspellings singulars plurals and
different stemming options so let's look
at a few examples to determine if a
keyword can show for a query
so in this case you have an exact match
keyword by plasma tv so the question is
will your ads show for these various
queries
so in our yes column we have the word by
plasma tv it's the exact same word it
will show
we have the word by plasma tvs it's
plural the same word just happens to be
a plural it will show
and our third example
plasma is misspelled but it's still by
plasma tv just a misspelling your ad can
show
in our next example buying plasma tv
it's a stem of the word buy by the
buying it's still plasma tv your ad
could show
i can show multiples of these conditions
also happen in the same query so in our
last example
buying it's a stemming plasma tvs it's a
plural it's still the same word just
happens to have a stemming and a plural
in it so your ad your exact match
keyword could show for any of those
queries
now in our no column
buy tv plasma it's a different word
order you're not going to show because
it's not the exact same orders matter as
well
we have someone buy a 42 inch plasma tv
there's additional words in the middle
of the query you're not going to show
in something like led tv completely
different words you're not going to show
so the main pro of this match type is
you have lots of control you know what a
user typed into a search engine and it's
usually best for your highest converting
words to put in an exact match to really
control
your bid for that keyword and how you're
displaying for it
now the con of this is it's fewer
impressions than other match types
because your ad is only displayed when
the search query matches your keyword so
our next match type is known as phrase
match
now phrase match keywords only cause an
ad to show if the query is contained
within your keywords so you can still
show for various word endings like
singulars plurals misspellings and so
forth
so let's look at some examples to see if
an ad can be displayed if you have the
keyword buy plasma tv in phrase match
will your ads show for these queries
so in our yes column by plasma tv it's
the same word you don't have to have
words before or after so you could show
where to buy plasma tvs
they're keywords in the query you've got
a plural that's okay
and those words before the actual
keyword by plasma tv but the word is in
the same order in the query there can be
additional words before after so the ad
could show
now third example we have a misspelling
it's still the same keyword by plasma tv
the ad could show
we could have multiple conditions where
by plasma tv
so
the words in the in the actual query
it's a misspelling it's fun there's not
a problem
the next one whereby plasma tv 42 inch
your keywords in the query there can be
words before and after in both
conditions the keyword but the keyword
is in the query in the same order
buying plasma tv 42 it's a stemming
option the keyword is still in the query
you're going to show but just word
afterwards
again there could be multiple conditions
buying plasma tvs42
it's a stemming
it's a plural there's a word after but
your main word is in the query in the
same order you could show under all
these conditions
now in our no column by tv plasma the
word order was switched not going to
show now
buy 42 inch plasma tv there's additional
words in the middle your query is by
plasma tv
42 inches in the middle of your keyword
it is not in the same order in the query
your right is not going to show
and some led tv you're not going to show
it's just completely different word so
pro is it's a medium control
it's more controlled than broad match
it's less an exact match
it has more impressions than exact match
because a user can add additional words
before or after or both
of your keyword within their query so
it's also good for for highly converting
words to use this one
now the cons are it's fewer impressions
than broad match because the word order
matters
and it's not as much control as exact
match with sort of a medium control
match type
now our third main match type is known
as broad match
with broad match
keywords can show an ad if the query is
related to the keyword so related is a
key here because related can mean a lot
of different things so you can show
again for singular plurals misspellings
and related words so if we have the
keyword buy plasma tv in broad match the
question is can we show for the query
so something like buy plasma tv same
word you can show by plasma tvs it's a
plural you could show as with the exact
phrase match
the third one's misspelling again you
could show from spellings or stemmings
or stems and plural
now something like buy tv
plasma
all your words are in the query the
order is different it doesn't matter
with broad match so something like buy
tv plasma as a query when your keywords
buy plasma tv
you would not show
exact or phrase because the word orders
flipped
broad match doesn't care about the word
order it says are all these words in the
query regardless of order or related
based version of that word
so something like buying led versus
plasma tvs
your words on the query lots of
additional words in the middle it's okay
all your keywords are in the query in
some spot
now someone like buy led television
you might show
for broad match because led and plasma
are related types of products so that's
a tough one to say because sometimes you
may show for a word like that sometimes
not but you can show for completely
different types of words and some
occasions with broad match as long as
they're related to each other
just something like buy dvd player
that's unrelated a player and a tv are
come different objects so what you
wouldn't show for by dvd player you
might show for by led tv
for a keyword like by plasma tv so the
pro is it's a lot of impressions because
related can take a lot of things into
account
so it can find lots of other queries
it's actually a great match type to
start with in many cases because you can
see sort of the universal queries for
keywords you don't have now the con is
it's very little control and it's
usually the lowest converting keywords
because you can show for some unrelated
items as well and we'll get to how to
control that a little bit later so look
at the the use cases for each keyword
exact match is the most control
it has the fewest impressions it's great
for direct response because you know
exactly what someone typed in
but it's not a lot of impressions so
phrase matches the middle ground your
keywords got to be in the query it can
show for misspellings plural so forth
the additional words added but your
keyword must be in the query in the same
order with phrase match so it's good for
direct response but a little more
impressions
broad match the lowest amount of control
but the most impressions so it's great
for branding
it's great for finding other queries
that may not be in your account
somewhere and go ahead and add those as
keywords as well
so match types determine how close to
related
the keyword your keyword must be the
query in order for your ad to be
displayed now there's times you don't
want an ad displayed
so this is what negative keywords are
good for negative keywords stop ads from
showing
now
negatives are a little different from
exact phrase match words
is they do not ever match to various
endings singulars plurals misspellings
stemming so forth so the advantage of
adding negative keywords is it removes
unwanted impressions you can keep your
ad from showing
so it blocks your ad from showing from
unrelated queries to your business
so for instance maybe you only sell
plasma tvs but you want to show for any
query related to plasma tv so you're
thinking broad match could be useful to
try some of
but you have no led televisions in your
entire inventory
but you know with broad match the word
plasma led could possibly show
so you could add the word led as a
negative keyword and whenever the word
led showed in the query your ad would
not show
so the canvas of using negatives is you
do lose impressions so you got to be
careful to only add negatives that you
really don't want to show for so let's
walk through an example
so let's say that you got the broad
match keyword plasma tv
and in that ad group your negative
keywords are 42 and led so the question
is will your ads show for these queries
so we're like buy plasma tv you can show
for the query
42 is not in the query led is not in the
query
for the second example
tvs plasmas versus leds
now the word led is in the query but
it's leds plural your negative is led
negatives do not ever match to singulars
plurals or stemming options so your ad
would show for something like tvs plasma
versus leds because it's not the exact
negative you added
now if someone search for plasma versus
led tv under our no column
led is in the query it's in your
negative keyword list you would not show
the second example by 42 inch plasma tv
42 is in the query your ad would not
show for this you know if someone typed
out by 42-inch plasma tv but they typed
f-o-r-t-y two they actually typed out
the word
what your ad would show because that's
not the actual negative keyword so as
you have different match types you're
getting negative keywords you're going
to show for a large variety of queries
but you have keywords in your account so
what the search terms report does is
show you the queries what someone typed
into a search engine in your account so
you can manage the actual search queries
so the search terms report it'll show
what a user typed in the engine along
with metrics like impressions clicks if
you're tracking conversions you can see
converted clicks and how much it costs
you to get a conversion for every single
one of those queries so then what you'll
do is you'll take a look at the search
terms you'll say
these are search terms that aren't
keywords in my account but they're
leading to conversions
so we want to make those keywords
you'll have other search terms they're
not in your account they're not keywords
but they're spending money and they're
not leading to actions those are good
negative keyword candidates so the
search terms reports a great place to do
research to determine should you add a
query as a keyword again queries that
someone typed in the engine keywords
what's in your account
or
is there's query just doesn't ever
convert so you want to make it a
negative keyword so you don't show this
any longer so let's recap our
information about match types so match
types determine how closely related the
search query and keyword must be before
your ad can be displayed
so exact match keywords only trigger an
ad to show when the query is the same as
your keyword phrase match causes your ad
to be displayed when the query is
contained within your keyword but there
can be words before or after or both of
your keyword
however if the word is not the query is
not in the exact same order as your
keyword your ad won't be displayed
remember both exact and phrase match
words can show for misspelling singulars
plurals and different endings the word
orders are very important exact and
phrase match never show for different
completely different words though
broad match words can show and add when
the query is related to your keyword
so with broad match the word orderings
no longer matter google looks to see
are all the words in your query or some
related terms of those queries in your
keyword if yes then you can show now
negative keywords they stop your app
from showing but negatives never match
the singulars plurals and different
stemming options
but if a negative keyword is anywhere in
the search query then your ad won't show
so the search terms report
search terms report shows you the actual
search query data so then the search
terms report is a great place to look at
to find words that aren't converting to
make them negatives or to find words
that are converting
that aren't in your account and make
them keywords so in the end match types
determine how close related your keyword
can be to the query for add to show
negatives stop your ad from showing the
search terms report
shows you the actual queries so you can
determine if there are new queries you
want to make into keywords or make into
negative keywords
so this concludes our information about
match types
you